Country Right now with all of you are on the front end of it because the rest of
the world is trying to catch up right now and the fact that you guys are here,
it shows that you saw at first and uh,
you were in for a treat for the next hour and a half,
so everybody give it up for Dr. Jordan.
Thank you.
I'm going to walk through.
I'm going to try to get through all the rules.
I don't think I've met him
once in London,
but I'm going to give you the background because there's two other things going
on in my life right now that I'm trying to sort out and I want to tie them
together and use this,
this chance to talk with you further.
Thinking on,
on all of these fronts simultaneously I got invited a week and a half to do
something that was really an overwhelming honor to me.
Um,
the pain with penguin books and in the UK is putting on the 50th anniversary
version of that.
Thanks.
I think it's hard to say.
No.
You can say.
Well,
I think that's the most important in the 20th century and maybe it's not,
but it's in the top 10 and we have an overwhelming impact on me and I want to
use the opportunity to write that introduction to do something that needs to be
done.
Um,
I was just in a debate on Saturday in Toronto called the debates and
debate.
Opponents to contend with was the idea that just as the,
as the radical right can go too far,
that's a claim of both,
which is virtually no disagreement except of course from the radical right.
A left and go far and historical evidence for that is called overwhelming is to
say almost nothing.
And one of the things I challenged my opponents to do was to say,
well,
how do you know when the radical left goes too far?
Because they can go too far.
You know,
one debate,
Michael Dyson,
he didn't answer the question at all.
There's not that he was compelled to or anything.
It was up to him.
And the other one said,
well,
you know,
when they become violent,
which to me is no answer golf because to say that people have gone too far when
they've gone too far,
isn't helpful
for all of us civilized people assuming that that's what we are are against
violence.
So it's not a very deep,
it's not a very deep analysis.
But the problem is that trying to figure out putting the radical left is going
to far is actually extraordinary,
extraordinarily difficult because there isn't something that appears to be a
smoking pistol.
You know,
when the radical right starts speaking claims of racial ethnic superiority and
then starts to react those up in the world.
You think,
okay,
well you guys are out with the game like that.
That's not acceptable.
You want in the domain of civilized dialogue anymore on the lab.
It's not so obvious when things go off the rails.
You know,
and one of the things that really like reading about reading the Gulag
archipelago,
I liked reading it because it's not going to do like to read.
It's slick.
The 1700 page scream of anguish,
you know,
it's tense,
tense.
But what Social India and I don't,
I think it was something that no one had really done before him was to lay out
the evidence that the absolute brutality of the Soviet Union was not an
aberration in relationship to Marxist thinking,
but a necessary consequence of Marxist thinking.
But the problem of course is that the argument spans something like 1700 pages
and that's not concise and I'm not criticizing you because of that,
because
because everything in that book needs to be in there as far as I can tell to in
the world to survive because there's things you have to eat and just sit there.
You die
in the world,
and even if you don't die,
we can just sit there and you're going to suffer.
And so the antidote to suffering in the world,
exactly what you're trying to do.
When you act in the world,
you're a preacher,
you're a 50 year particular physiology reflects that extraordinary.
What you're trying to do in the world is to,
is to make things better than they are.
When you're hungry,
to try to feed yourself,
find some uranium.
You're taking care of your family so they don't suffer.
You're,
you're,
you're orienting yourself towards something about and so the first proposition
is you limited world.
Your frame of reference is valiantly.
Essentially what you're doing is moving always from a place that isn't as good
as it could be to a place that someone edit and you see the world through that
Lens.
You're at point a and you're going to point B and point B is better than point a
and so because if it wasn't for why would you bother with it?
Why would you put in the time and effort if what you're moving towards is better
than what you have?
It's a matter of definition.
Even that if you're acting for words a damn,
unless you've decided to make things worse,
and sometimes people do.
If you're acting towards it and you're acting out the proposition that what
you're acting towards is bending with what you have and so there's no escaping.
The world is valued.
Proposition number one and this proposition number two would be there's no
escaping the social world,
so if you act other value proposition,
you're going to do it socially because you're surrounded by people.
You're not.
No Man is an island as they say,
and so if you've worked out the proposition that one thing is better than
another,
it's going to do that with other people and you're going to cooperate with them
and compete with them in relationship to that endeavor.
If you go to law school,
some people are better at school than others.
You go to the source therapist and some people have a natural talent for that.
It's like so,
so what that means essentially,
and I think this is a universal truth.
I think that as soon as you implement the value structure in a social situation
and produced a hierarchy,
and I think that we know that,
I think that's respected and phenomena like the freedom distribution and price
law,
that you formulate a hierarchy.
Some people are better at whatever the hierarchy is than others and most people
start to stack up at the boss so you get disproportionate success.
At the top along of minority,
and that's a well established,
that's bookmarks,
absurd.
Even though he made a specific case of it,
he said,
well,
pretend to accumulate the hands of fewer,
fewer people.
He met the same people across time and he thought it was only wealth as far as I
can tell,
and
and they made a number of other mistakes at all over talking to at the moment.
So okay,
so you have to act out value in the world and if you do so you're gonna produce
a higher in a new producer,
higher you can produce winners and losers and that actually is a problem because
of this electric of it has been.
It's actually quite painful than your hierarchy is pretty inclusive,
especially if they really lose because if you lose the now,
if you're way down to zero,
then if you don't have enough to eat,
you don't have medical care like it gets painful happened.
It's happened.
Not because it's logically appropriate.
Anyways,
so hard about that for a long time with our higher is because what it means is
that
the reality that we face isn't the reality of a hierarchy.
It's the set of possible
and the rules that govern operation in a reality that consists of a set of
higher piece aren't the same rules that govern success in a hierarchy.
So I can give you a quick example of that.
So imagine you have a child who's playing the game.
Soccer,
let's say,
um,
for fucking,
since it's Boston Canadian.
No,
your kids play hockey and we'd have Easter Gospel clarity,
but he's a little stingy with poc and uh,
and you know,
he plays a game.
You and he comes off the ice and they lose and,
and stick down at the Smith has a little temper tantrum and uh,
you know,
you,
you have some sense.
So you take them aside and say,
look,
it doesn't matter whether you win or lose,
it's how you play the games.
And he's not happy to hear that because you kind of have a bit of a pout and he
looks at you like there's something wrong with you and he doesn't know what you
mean because of course he's trying to win and you probably encouraged him to
win.
And so when you come out and say,
well,
the win or a how you play the game,
he doesn't know what you mean.
And then when he asked you what do you mean you don't know,
you don't always make your own rules predictory across the set of all possible
hierarchy,
but the rules were within one higher.
And what you're basically telling your job is don't sacrifice the manner in
which you would behave when the set of possible games for victory won your game.
And that's because black isn't a hockey game.
It's also not a series of kids.
It's more like a series of hockey games than like one day.
But life is a series of hierarchies,
a series of games.
And you might say,
well how do you win a series of games?
And one answer to that is you get invited to play a lot of them.
Anybody that does that,
there's an almost an indefinite number of ways of interpreting the world.
And then that's kind of split the postmodernism,
say the 1966.
But how do you know how you should interpret a book?
Fiction.
There's plenty ways to interpret a piece of fiction after our people.
Well,
how many stable way of interpreting and if there's no stable way of interpreting
it,
well,
how do you rank our per patient?
How do you know what interpretation is better than the other on they're actually
what you can.
And so you don't.
And so there's no such in a sense,
there's no reliable judge of quality literature.
It's arbitrary.
Well,
artificial intelligence people bond at the same time trying to make machines to
proceed the world.
It turns out the borders between things are so easily drawn when we look at the
world and I can see your own blind spots,
no effort on my part.
I just see it.
But you know,
there's three and a half billion years of evolution when into that.
It's an easy problem,
I can solve it,
but not because of any particular color than mine,
right?
I'm the beneficiary of all this adds and all the selection.
When they did that for three and a half,
building your process,
that doesn't mean it's easy.
It wouldn't have taken old.
That gap and all those years to manage it was easy because it very large number
of ways of interpreting rope.
That does not mean that there's a very large number of ways of interpreting the
world and that's where the postmodernists gone seriously wrong.
So because think about the constraints that the one you with regards to how you
have to improve the world.
First of all,
you can't just sit there or you'll suffer and die.
So you have to go out there and act in the world and that means there's,
there's problems.
You have to solve it or basically grounded in your motivational structure.
You know,
you have to eat,
you have to find water,
you have to find shelter,
you have to regulate your temperature.
You have to play with others.
You have to find a mate.
You have to.
You have to pursue something that produces a certain amount of positive
emotional pain,
don't want to be anxious like and you don't like you coming quit with all of
those systems and also for your attention and so you have to address those
issues or or things that are critical Disney for you when it's worse than so not
only are you are you governed by those biological God's let's say and are in
some sense they're there,
but you have to figure out how to address those problems today because you're
not just going to be around today.
You're going to be on today,
tomorrow,
next week and next month.
We're now in five years from now,
10 years from now,
so whatever solution you come up with today,
which might be,
let's draw the bank,
has the word down the road and let's rob a bank.
Mike worked quite nicely today and next week,
but as a five year strategy,
it's a problem with the idea of the one.
We know that because you can say,
well,
don't be an impulsive.
Well why not?
Well,
because it's medium to longterm strategy.
That's.
That's why it doesn't work very well.
Polarization
in society,
and I think the universities are
degrees and I think it's partly because the intelligentsia isn't west,
has never prompted to come to terms with their
listening complicitness in it.
What happened in radical left societies be sorted out
and
published lubricant.
It became for a time completely unacceptable to profess intellectual
admiration for the Marxist doctrine,
but and I think what happened in France,
the French intellectuals,
the people who dominate the particularly pathological end of the social sciences
and the humanities in the university has played the sleight of hand and
transformed them that now ultimately toxic Marxism into the current theories of
identity politics playing out in front of us where the proper we to look.
The world is the war against every other group with a narrative,
the whole pressure,
oppressor and victim,
and that leads nowhere.
Good
on the left leads to exactly
leads to college campuses that are so repressive.
Premiums will go tell jokes.
They're in more a good thing because the tyrant is definitely someone who
doesn't like Comedians,
especially as they're making fun of you because especially if you have any
authority because maybe they'll remind you of why you're going and you went into
attire and that would be a good thing to be developed.
We hope for as your level of authority increases the west,
that's where you want to hit this real
subjective experiences like meeting are real.
It's not a strong theory about as far as I'm concerned,
I think that you can make a very strong case and I think you could make
scientific case for this as well.
That meaning is an extension of the sense of need and invalid when you're doing
something worthwhile is actually the most profound to instinct that you have.
It's the most reliable thing there is.
It's the most real thing.
I spent quite a bit of time studying how the brain works and you have instincts
that orient you towards learning a very fundamental instinct.
This is called the orientee,
reflexively discovered by Russian neuropsychologist back in the 19 sixties.
You Orient towards things that surprise you and that's what opens the door to
learning and you can optimize that process of learning methods,
zone of proximal development,
but therapists,
Zocor or something like that,
and it's an indication that you're living on the edge.
On the edge is where secure.
Stabilize yourself
out there.
Don't understand.
It's an exciting place to be a lecturer and meaningful place in the region.
It's a meaningful place.
That's actually where you should be.
You're secure,
you're practicing what you don't,
but you're getting better at it over time.
It's a place where your adaptation in the real sense is expanding at an optimal
rate.
It's a place where you're offering so you're going to be in a way that suits
you,
read to the future in a way that's going to be good for your family when it's
going to be good for your community.
So all these things stack up.
Harmonious sense of meaning tells you when you're orienting reflects that helps
you identify where you should be standing,
wherever you are,
wherever you should be communicating,
listening,
wherever you are.
If you pay attention to that advertisement in meaning been,
first of all,
you have meaningful life,
which is a very useful thing,
but secondly,
you are exactly where you should be right here now,
so that's a good thing to note too,
because the meeting madness certainly have pain as a meeting.
I know this trick of argument.
You're so fucking bad.
It's not very useful,
so we can certainly establish that.
Maybe you
might say,
well,
what about the meetings that help you transcend the pain and suffering?
Turns out they are the most critical thing.
What looks like to
me about the whole week in front of the idea I'm facing the and restructuring
was her own reflections of the same.
The idea of facing the dragging until people like all of that,
almost ancient heroic ideas and ideas that are associated with an emergent
ethnic girl.
Variants of the same thing.
Girl,
our attempts to picture what it would be like to be the proper human being.
Religious stories heard attempt,
but if you were ever thinking it could be,
what would you be like?
Oh,
it's pretty complicated because you're really complicated.
All we can get images and stories,
but what might be like,
we can't articulate it fully,
what were you,
what we all need to be in that because it's the thing that will redeem us from
the house
and so
on.
A roll.
No,
this isn't just a battle between two arbitrary ways of interpreting the world.
One of those ways is wrong.
It's the
wrong.
You just leads to catastrophe rounded property infrastructure,
reality,
but the idea of individual who bears the burden of being property faces his or
her suffering in front school level,
who faces the unknown restructures society would.
It becomes tyrannical at ethic of fair play and courage that's deep.
The were oriented towards.
It manifests itself in our instinct for it.
It allows us to live with ourselves,
the clear conscience,
able to everything we have accepts our social world,
right?
And keeps us a good distance away from.
And that's what we could do and that's where we need to be
thanked
for just a second.
Just to stretch his legs.
Friends,
the job where you're going to take care of shit.
Now
you're hiring
somebody.
All right,
so here's what we're gonna do,
so we're going to do a q and a,
so you guys submitted questions and there's literally hundreds here,
which I picked out some of the best ones.
I've actually loved the into Jordan's computer right now,
which means I could jump on twitter and end this whole fucking thing
quite close.
Alright,
so we're going to do a little q and a here.
Everyone feel good?
We're all good.
Thank you
Jordan.
Thank
you first because this is a 10th or 11th and I'm not kidding.
When I tell people you are different every single month and is that part of your
plan?
Know
pretty good
audience because then you can see what you're saying.
Makes Sense.
That's the whole,
that's the secret of free speech in some stamps strength because that's how you
think.
It's just the thing
to see what we're thinking.
We're going do that by communicating with people and seeing what happens when
you see where the consequences are.
I've been in a battle in some sense in Canada
with people who are
so they're so careless that they think it's okay to introduce legislation that
restricts people's.
Asked me to communicate like I don't get that.
It's a sin
to this political debate,
let's say,
but it's not political as far as I'm concerned.
What's happened is that the politicians did something that wasn't political
thing jumped outside of their proper domain of,
of activity.
It was like they went down to the constitutional level or even lower than that,
so.
Well,
it's okay.
You can mess around with this.
It's like it's not okay.
You're not gonna.
Justify telling people what did they can say on the ground with some fictitious
compassion,
freedom nonfic dishes to passion for that.
First of all,
thank you.
Don't,
because you're kind of predict the supreme court ruled that compelled speech was
unconstitutional.
Thank you.
How do you remain so calm in the face of overwhelming close mindedness?
I don't know.
If I do.
I'm probably.
There are much less than would appear in public,
so my family,
my wife who's hiding somewhere in the audience.
Thank that.
I have pretty good support network is very much with being on this kids or
parents
or friends around me watch me going through all this and criticizes me when they
think it's necessary,
know,
have all of this clinical experience that helps you.
When I talk with Katherine Newman and
she.
She
sat down and talked to her when the cameras were off.
She was quite friendly and then the counters when she was a whole different
person and I saw that
don't be thinking you
don't
know
what's going on here,
but it just.
So I just watched her and I
figured out almost immediately that whoever she was interviewing for no
resemblance to me.
Interesting.
Talking to journalists and I think the New York Times article is a good example
of that was that was a strange experience because the young woman who wrote that
article,
she hung around with me for about two days and she was in my house,
my house when she called the Chamber of horrors,
which
does have some rough in because
she was.
She was very friendly,
very open to it.
I'm very supportive and engaged and apparently during that was true and
he might say,
well,
why bother talking to journalists and that sort of thing happens is first of
all,
it doesn't happen all the time by many,
many journalists.
It's like 200 newspapers in Canada a year ago came up with support what it was
doing,
so you have to keep the map.
The good.
Can't complain about that,
but more importantly,
I think it's not so bad.
People revealed their hands.
If you talk to people and watched and listen,
then they revealed your hands so everyone can see what they're playing and
that's happened to me
40 times.
Probably maybe more in the last two years.
People come after me and say,
well,
you must be this
incarnation of a saint tammany figure your way.
That's not true
and what's happening in various that it's been harder on the journalists than on
me and I'm not calling people to continue.
In fact,
I have good friends who think that the New York Times basically some as a
respectable figure,
but I'm actually concerned with being respectful.
So you're saying if you want to sleep with tech,
you could ask one question.
Alright.
I'd like to ask them how you figured out what I figured out
things
incalculably intelligent.
You know,
when I read,
I read everything he wrote in the 19 nineties about stuff wasn't like I
understood all of it because it's tough going and I've just done to figure out
how he can figure out what you did.
Maybe you have maybe you know,
people do one in a billion.
No,
maybe it was one in a billion so he could see things that I can't figure out how
anyone
see
if you have a gift for imagination,
you know,
some people are very good at articulation,
every good thinking in words and some people are good at thinking in pictures
and he seemed to be really good at both.
You know,
we had a tremendous advantage.
Dream essentially infant learn how to do that and seem to learn all sorts of
things from his weekend dreams.
If I can do that little bit.
Sometimes when I'm doing therapy with people,
for example,
I'll be listening to the clinical picture of my head or a little fragment of the
story.
No,
what country it comes with,
imagery and it's sort of in background and then I'll notice it and then I'll
tell them,
look when you said that this happened in my imagination,
we can take apart the relationship between what they said and what happened in
my imagination that usually ship substantial light on what's going on.
But he was an absolute master at that.
So I do.
I find out from him how he managed that and maybe you could say it,
but I sure like to know I've met anyone like that.
So there were a couple of questions here asking you to clarify.
It's forced.
Phenomenal.
Should we bust out their phones for this one recording of this?
If you can do it in two minutes and we'll throw it up on twitter.
Yeah.
You guys want to punch out your phones for this one just so we get some video
with your answers for the
enemies respond well to.
So I'll,
I'll ask the question.
So the question is,
what do you mean by force without doing well?
We could start by saying,
don't be.
I don't mean taking innocent women at gunpoint and happy over to useless man
accusation.
It was really interesting to watch that unfold.
What I meant was that monogamy as,
uh,
as something that's socially valued is,
appears to be essentially a human universal.
That doesn't mean that human beings are universally monogamous because officers,
we're not serially monogamous in.
Some people have multiple partners and all of that,
but here's a strong proclivity across.
No society can tilt towards monogamy and the enforcement is social norms.
Think about it and I can't believe that I have to say this
just gets buried.
And he comes home and he says,
Dad,
I've been screwing around.
Know
you're not happy about that.
And he doesn't count because he knows you're not going to be happy about it.
And that's the fourth monogamy.
It's part of the social structure.
It's like what?
It's like.
Well,
most people want a monogamous relationship and if they enter into a relationship
with someone,
they're not happy.
If that person goes to the surround view,
he would be happy.
If that happens.
That's part of enforced.
It's part of this moment and you might have noticed the problem.
Get polygamy is actually illegal.
You.
It's
be known for 100 years after most of whom are left leaning by the way,
because that's how it goes.
That monogamous social structures are one of the ways we keep children
raised property so that they have a relatively stable environment and then you
keep male aggression,
especially the aggression of young men under some degree of social control.
It's not a mystery.
The fact that I got in trouble for that is it's kind of a miracle foot
notice that worth it.
Like almost every way.
The same thing happens all over the world and alternative diverse societies and
then when we deviate from that,
there's a price to be paid so and so.
That's why like I'm a New York Times pariah is because I think the minority all
things considered is a good idea.
Thank
you.
So
do you have any advice for someone who correctly identified versus a bad choice
but has difficulty following
through
Christ
to someone
who is white?
It's harder to do the right thing off that because of
the precedent for the future is the sacrificial gesture to do
sacrifice and so interesting.
It's one of the things I about quite a bit in promos to figure that out.
I'm really happy about that,
that I sent them ritual sacrifice.
You know,
you read a book sacrificial rituals,
what those people up to,
no burden.
It's like
one of the most fundamental discoveries that human beings ever made.
It's absolutely unbelievable that we figured out that you can sacrifice
something of value in the president,
gain something of value in the future.
That's the future,
right?
That's the delayed gratification scaffold on which context,
thanks
before we can understand it,
and so that's what those rituals were about,
was acting that out for thousands of years before we can say,
well,
what sort of sacrifices did your parents think?
And here's what we know,
what the sacrificial is.
So it's difficult to sacrifice the present for the future because it means the
foregoing of gratification,
you know,
you need to be gratifying now,
have some water now.
You have to have sex now,
but for the future is also we'll.
So you have to learn how to balance the future was the precedent.
That's hard.
And I would say,
well you do that the same way.
If you do that for yourself,
the same what you do for a child that you care for it is that you,
you,
you discipline yourself gently.
And the way you do that is by setting yourself tasks that are hard but possible.
You know,
you have to get up in rule four,
I think it is.
Compare yourself with who you were yesterday and with some,
with someone else's today,
it's like what you want to do is be a little better than you were yesterday.
And you might say what's a little bit,
well,
it has to be announced so that you're happy if it happens,
but not so little,
but it's a trivial accomplishment.
And then he kind of calibrated.
It's like you know,
you're not interested in playing a game that you can win every time.
You're kind of a full,
under no circumstances do you want to have a pretty decent shot at winning,
but maybe that your skill improves while you're playing it,
so that's what did you set yourself a task and think,
well,
I can probably in this,
it's a little bit outside of my zone of comfort.
Let's say it's a little bit of white habitual practice,
but I think I can do it tomorrow.
I can do it for a week,
and then if you can't do it while they lower your sights a little bit now,
lower your sights,
tell you a little better,
then you think,
oh,
there's my zone.
I can I can improve at this rate.
You'll find that that's a meaningful place to be.
It wouldn't be at the place where you could improve a little bit constantly and
you can find that experiment that takes humility,
right?
Jennifer,
because you're not as good at getting better as you think you.